the end of December holidays are
stressful times for a lot of people
sometimes it's because of travel
sometimes it's because of maybe seeing
family you don't really want to see you
or at least it's stressful to see some
people just get stressed out realizing
another year has gone by and you only
went to the gym for that first week of
January and then forgot about it or
whatever if you are under more than a
dozen investigations and responsible for
destroying the economy of the United
States it's probably even more stressful
as evidenced by Donald Trump being on
tilt for this long holiday weekend that
were coming back from with just wacky
behavior followed by even wackier
behavior and this includes tweeting a
picture of himself apparently signing a
stack of blank bills or executive orders
seeming to have no text on them and also
tweeting completely erratically the
tweets first I already showed you some
of trumps erratic tweets here's a pity
me Trump tweet from over the holiday
weekend where he said quote I am all
alone poor me in the White House waiting
for the Democrats to come back and make
a deal on desperately needed border
security at some point the Democrats not
wanting to make a deal will cost our
capital see country more money than the
capitalized border wall we are all
talking about crazy very strange tweet
blaming Democrats when Republicans
control everything I'm all alone at the
White House very very weird but then it
gets even stranger right before the
shutdown started at midnight during the
holiday break that we had Trump went on
Twitter and again slammed Democrats and
pointed to all the bills he's signing in
the Oval Office check out this tweet
where he said quote some of the many
bills that I am signing in the Oval
Office right now and he's pictured next
to a huge stack of bills about as tall
as his head canceled my trip on Air
Force One to Florida while we wait to
see if the Democrats will help us to
protect America's southern border but
something is weird about this picture if
you look at just the picture people
started noticing that it wasn't evident
that there was actually any text
on the bill that Donald Trump is signing
and if you zoom in on just the paper you
also notice that there appears to be no
text on it whatsoever now you could say
well the angle is making it so it's hard
to see the text or the lighting is
making it so it's hard to see the text
we're not seeing anything they're not
the big title of whatever he's signing
not the line he should be using that big
sharpie to sign on so it appears as
though Trump staged a picture of himself
signing all sorts of bills that are just
blank like it's just a stunt the
government's shutting down the economy's
in freefall and Donald Trump appears to
be staging photo ops with fake bills to
sign now for people saying that one had
nothing on it for security reasons but
all the other stack of bills is real
well the other problem is that there's a
website gov track dot u.s. which looks
at bills that are passed two bills are
listed for the date of the tweet and no
bills are listed for the few days
following which you would imagine if
Donald Trump is signing this big stack
of bills they would show up somewhere as
bills or executive orders that Donald
Trump has signed so this is outrageously
funny but there's a more serious
implication here let's look again at the
tweet the Donald Trump put out about
this he said some of the many bills that
I'm signing in the Oval Office right now
canceled my trip on Air Force One to
Florida while we wait to see if the
Democrats will help us to protect the
border he's saying that he's only
signing these bills now I mean they
appear to be fake bills but it doesn't
matter he's claiming that Democrats
refusing to give him what he wants on
the border wall caused him to cancel his
trip to Florida which are causing him to
sign all of these bills in aren't the
bills either bills that should be signed
or shouldn't be signed and even if he
was going to Florida he could be signing
them on the plane like isn't this
extraordinarily dangerous Pat that he's
saying when I don't get what I want from
Democrats I sign bills sooner shouldn't
each bill be signed on the basis of how
important it is and what it does and
what the timing of it should be
regardless of playing politics
yeah this falls apart on so many
different levels and couldn't Eve just
put a little bit of effort into the lie
like he could have printed something out
printed out a fake bill and sign the
thing and then took the photo I don't
know why he wouldn't put in that little
bit of effort and also remember that
Trump did take credit for the government
shutdown he told Schumer and Pelosi that
he would take the mantle
I guess he's rescinded on that I don't
know at this point whether he says he
shut down the government or he had to do
it because of Democrats or Democrats
shut down the government the content of
this particular tweet is lies the
implications are childish and petulant
the photo-op appears to be a staged lie
he's using that huge dumb Sharpie as
usual and he looks generally out of
place in the Oval Office and the world
is laughing more and more loudly at us
because of this man and instead of
actually dealing with the increasing
list of problems that we have he's
signing blank bills to be able to tweet
about it in the Oval Office
extraordinarily disturbing